(electronic music)
- Hey, are you my doctor?
- Not anymore.
I'm off to become a world
famous knife juggler.
- What?
- But don't worry, I
called you an Uber.
- I don't need an Uber,
man, I need a doctor.
- Bye forever.
- Ah!
What?
What the?
♪ Money
Dollar bills♪
♪ I got money, I got
money, I got money
♪ I got money, I got money
♪ I got money, I got
money, I got--♪
- Nick?
- Blue lab coat?
- Yeah, how you doin' today?
Can I get you something?
Want a mint?
Maybe a bottle of water?
Is the temperature okay?
- No, it's fine, stop.
- Well let's see, the app says
that you just came
out of a coma.
Ima google that and
see what that is.
- You don't even
know what a coma is?
Aren't you a doctor?
- Nah, man, this is
just my side hustle.
My f'reals passion
is making house music
mixed up, mashed up
with 911 phone calls.
- I need real professional care.
How is this fuckin' legal?
- You want a lawyer,
dude, you gotta call Lyft.
- What?
- Yeah, alright.
(hip-hop music)
So there's this big time
video producer, right,
and he's got this mansion.
He's got these like
champagne ladies.
He's got like these
tigers and stuff.
It's gonna be like sexy.
- (coughing) I can't breathe!
- I know, I can't
believe it either.
Aw hell yeah, I
got an UberPOOL.
Sorry, I've gotta
get another patient.
- Hurry, the blood is
staining the wheelchair.
- Ahhhhhh, oh man!
What are you, like
a knife juggler?
(coughing)
Sorry, dude.
I gotta take care of
this dude 'cause he's
got like knives in him, so,
do you mind, like,
waiting a minute?
- (choking) I can't wait!
(machine flat lining)
- Five stars!